foreign
welcome back to the true Geordie podcast
today's guest is Ben Foster all right
man thank you uh we had a good little
chat before this and I'm really excited
to talk to you today because I
discovered your book recently and
um I haven't read loads of it because I
was like I've got to talk to this guy I
want this to be sort of like fresh but
on the back of the book the title is
Gigolo yes and some people may or may
not know what that means uh broadly
speaking it means male prostitute yeah
yeah and
like something that I'm not really hit
with on a day-to-day basis so obviously
my eyes are drawn to it and on the back
of the book it says um Ben qualifies as
a masseur and is uh introduced to the a
mysterious committee which was a group
of society women with one big thing in
common they adore sex and don't mind
paying for it you were a care worker who
was drawn into a world of private jets
sex clubs State Secrets endless lines of
cocaine orgies and country houses with a
who's who of celebrities MPS and the
International Super Rich yes
such a normal block
um but then when I started talking to
you
I immediately understood what women
would enjoy about you which is that you
are a very caring person
yes and that really comes across that
you're not a judgmental person you make
people feel very comfortable and in my
experience with women that's the best
way to go definitely definitely so I
guess we should try and and take a
little time machine back to the start
mate of you know how did this sort of
begin
I started my career off in the fishing
charters which is completely far away as
far away as you can get for sports
therapy and things like that at all and
found a Sports Therapy course I went on
to that and to cut all the gray bits out
I moved away we moved to London and I
just started working in the exclusive
spa retreat
this is where I met a lot of people
um obviously the Ayla celebrities and
the TV personalities and things like
that and that was obviously legit and
stuff then I worked also for a little
bit of part-time first time man in the
gym and while I was in the gym I got
approached by let's say a part of the
royal family mentioning no names
and he basically said do you do private
treatments you know I'm not really keen
on coming here stuff like that so
basically we arranged to meet and uh the
first time I drove up there was this big
stately Helm in the Cotswolds of all
places while I was there uh the mother
of this gentleman basically took an eye
to me and within five minutes I was
meeting the whole Committee of ladies as
I like to call them
and being provided around a room with
like pictures that you're probably worth
more than my my whole house was worth
you know and things like that so what
was the first time someone suggested
that this was more than a massage uh the
first time I kind of got roped into it
um I was it was the mother of the person
that I was seeing she basically gave me
a mobile phone uh an honest mobile phone
was one number my number and the
committee's numbers so they'd text me
anytime they wanted and I would go and
be whatever they wanted me to be on that
occasion whether it was a dinner dance
or literally just sex
um I basically got invited to do a
treatment for the mother and while I was
there at the time I was driving and the
oldest bang you could ever wish for in
your life you know I'm humbled again
less about the mother no yeah yeah
[Laughter]
when I went there next thing you know my
car broke down I couldn't start it and I
had to stay in this stately home for the
night okay
I laid there I suppose about Harvest 11
at night we'd had drinks and chats you'd
had a massage fantastic beautiful figure
beautiful lady
they all are you know
um next thing you know there she stood
at the bottom of my bed white sat and
sort of thing she had I still remember
to this day
and she just dropped it off and stood
there completely naked and the
confidence was something that I wasn't
used to at the time because most of the
girls I've been with were cover up and
hide and not you're not into confidence
but I mean if you're in your early
twenties women in their early 20s
naturally are going to be less confident
um and I'm assuming because she was in a
position of authority she's like well I
don't really care if you judge me or not
you're here to be used essentially yes
yes so can you remember specifics and
and and would you share a little bit of
like I don't know how she was and that
sort of stuff because it is this is so
unusual here yes yeah definitely I mean
brunette brown eyes lovely sort of tan
skin you know the the olive sort of skin
um
as far as the sexual side of things
basically she Implement and start off by
Oral
um kissing and things like that and just
relax I mean to be honest with the back
of my mind was thinking where's your
husband where you know is he going to
burst in any minute now or you know I've
seen a few things in my life as you know
being a diver you know
um and at that point it kind of went
from you know her on top and then it was
doggy and then before you know it we
were by the window the windows were open
the grates were open the booze you know
there's probably still the imprint is
still on the glass
that was all down to me
um the treatment the massage itself like
I said have you done the treatment in a
fireplace and this is where I thought
that would have happened but it didn't
and then later on did you make any
suggestions during that or any movements
because you know how like I mean you
could only imagine that sometimes women
would position things in a certain way
if they want you to touch certain areas
but that never happened no it was it was
I felt like I was being interviewed it
was more questions where are you from
what did you do where did you come from
and all this sort of thing and each time
she's going hmm and I can see now I look
at it now I think in the back of my mind
she's thinking I'm going to ruin you
later you know you're obviously young
like I said so for her it's probably a
good thing
um but um I kind of if you pardon the
pun fell into it without even realizing
before you know it like I said I had a
car I had a phone I was going around to
all these women after work and after a
full day's work and in between work it
was like dinner but quick we can you
know go and do this I got addicted to it
as well again me being the person that I
am and it's like I say to my clients now
um you know I know what I can do and I
know what I'm capable of
so I'll let you give me what you think
I'm worth that was one of my most
favorite sayings I know it sounds crazy
it's never about the money I've never
been money orientated I think everything
I've done was done on a physical mental
emotional level and obviously spiritual
level everything I do is is you know if
I talk to someone give a treatment
everything's got to be covered it can't
just be like oh you're physically sorted
out because the person might be there
just want to chat so to speak nine times
out of ten as I say nine times out of
ten let's say four times out of ten the
lady would be in tears after the ACT
because our emotions have gone wild we
know that ladies are completely
different their chemicals in their body
when a man makes love to a woman is very
emotional it means they're attached to
you based on what it says on the book
just just so that people understand with
his dark hair blue eyes and robust
appendage that the ladies dub Big Ben
I'll tell you what that's not a bad CV
no 100 it isn't and obviously that
attracts all the wrong people yeah but I
mean you know there's been times where
I've been a ladies company and she has
literally just thrown on the plate for
me and I've said no if you look Kitty
going I'll take it home
and because that's my moral side of
things that's not you know for them I
suppose it's just the same I slept with
Ben Foster hey you know and for me it's
not no I'm not you know I'd rather sit
and have a conversation with you that
side of things for me there's only one
room in the house that I'll ever be in
command of and that is the bedroom when
it comes to any relationship the lady
has the room in the house she does
everything she wants but that room is my
room I get to say what happens in there
and I think that's the thing as well
with relationships I mean I've been
married myself and you know you you look
at your partner and she's the one she's
the one for you don't look look at
anything else and you know you kind of
get into but you can't look at that
partner anymore is that person you wanna
forgive me for saying it like this but
ruin you want to [__] her brains out not
being rude enough and you want to have
the best night of your life with your
partner but you've got so much respect
for this girl that you can't see her
like that you've made a very interesting
conversational point there because
there's a there's a phrase that a couple
of my mates have used in the past called
putting the [__] on a pedestal yes and
once you start looking at her in a
certain way where you have a lot of
respect for her
then the the the feeling of wanting to
dominate her or to you know as a Ruiner
like though some of those urges can
change because for for some of my mates
when we've had those conversations
specifically when they become the mother
of their children yes you when a woman
gives you a child and and you know you
you look at her in a in a way that's
like almost you know you kind of look at
her as a mother figure a miracle yeah
you look at her as a [__] not
necessarily your mother but a but a
figure of respect yeah you know you
adore that so then think of her like the
porn star there we go it's def it's
difficult because women have to be so
many different things to a man 100 and
it's all up here you know and as for a
man as you get older it's all up here
yeah you can think what's going on down
here when you're young while you're
young enjoy it that's all I'm gonna say
because as you get older you'll start to
think to yourself actually I've got to
pick up some bread on the way home you
know and you start to think I'm in the
middle of this and why is my head going
through a bread that I've got to pick up
from a shop it drives me nuts and it is
just older
a lot easier and as you say
um you're fully loaded and the and these
women are wanting to feel that
exhilaration that they used to feel when
they were young women yeah and this is
different because of the age of some of
the girls but I look at the Jeffrey
Epstein story where he was being
receiving massages from young women yes
and then it would go from that to sex
when you look at your story high society
you know women of power and you being a
young wet behind the ears man it's not
that dissimilar and I just don't know if
you were of of a mental age where you
were able to really understand what was
happening there definitely not I mean
like I said I was still young and you
know like you said young dumb and Fuller
come and the same side of things as well
it was also mentioned to me on numerous
occasions that they could destroy me if
they wanted to obvious see with the
information well then there's definitely
sex trafficking because because you're
being coerced with threats of of
whatever can happen because these are
extremely powerful people I thought they
just made me disappear to be honest with
you that was honestly and like like I
said this was the part where up here
I struggled for a lot of years because
it was like oh God it was going to be a
red dot on me anytime now your brain
goes off on one doesn't it you you look
at films and you think am I the next
victim but it was just a gentle reminder
it was very subtle in other words what
we've got on you could destroy you as
much as it could us
um you know there weren't no Foams
allowed in the room you know we were
searched things like that and I wasn't
the only person that was being paid to
be there there was lots of people young
ladies there there was also young men
there what what do you think the
youngest person you've seen I think the
youngest I'd say would probably be
between 17 and 18. uh you know I
couldn't safely I think any if there was
anything like that going on in the other
rooms and I'd been kept well away from
it I mean these guys protect themselves
for a reason it seems these days they
don't need to they can pretty much do
what they want and say yeah we're going
to do it anyway
uh looking back at the the accusations
that have been made about certain
members of the royal family has has did
that raise any eyebrows with you or were
you just like yep I I knew and this is
the thing I was sitting there with
colleagues and stuff and they come on
the Telly and things like that and I'd
be sitting there thinking believe me if
I sat in now and I'm sitting there
thinking oh my God you know I've seen
you in a situation where you've been
wearing a nappy and someone's been
chasing you around the dummy you know
it's it's ridiculous I mean you know
some people ask me to put them in a cage
and just leave them there for an hour
and abuse them choke some water on them
and stuff and they pay you for that I
mean that's just ridiculous it's like
they're each to their own you know if
you want to identify as a raindrop you
go ahead that's up to you or you know
I'm quite happy being me so it speaks
how often did it get weird like that
with uh these people I think it's the
boredom Factor they've got all this
money and all this time and nothing to
do so it's kind of like they search out
for the fast cars and the crazy thing
that's why a lot of celebrities go off
the rails I believe because they get
bored they they want something to do
they've had them money they've got to
the top what's next I mean there was
there was one occasion the gentleman you
know very very important person that's
all I'm going to say has a lot to do
with the law and he offered me literally
three thousand pound to spend the night
with him and I was like no I'm sorry I
was just just females only I felt a
little bit pressured because I was a bit
like right you can stay over there now
mate you know I mean it's very powerful
man as well yes I want more upset input
that way and you know it's the biggest
gang in the company let's just say that
um story short the sun went up to ten
thousand pound and I still said no
obviously for all the right reasons and
you know there's just something that I
couldn't do that's not for me it doesn't
float my boat
so cleverly when the ladies took me to
the room and he sat there and watched
when a gentleman you know you've got a
lady bent over so it's big and you're
you're doing your business and
everything like that
um it comes up and he tries to touch
your ass so to speak and there's me but
what are you doing mate no I'm not like
that you know that was a big issue a lot
because let's be honest there's more men
out there that would go for the services
than there is a women I mean that that's
the hardest thing a lot of women have
said to me in the past I can't
understand why someone would pay for it
so I've said to them you come out for a
night with me and you after the night
you tell me whether I'm worth it or not
and a little bit for my own ego you know
it is holding my hands up every time
yeah completely different to what I used
to the one thing they say to me is I'm
doomed and I say why is that and they
say because I'm never going to find
someone that's done what you've just
done to me in that what is it that you
think makes your experience with a woman
that much different to a normal guy
simply the fact of taking your time you
know take your time and read the woman a
lot of people they go rushing into these
things quick Bam Bam you know let's do
this let's do that watch a porn film
make up one no no no no get on on a
mental level first of all if you get in
their head first and then you know ease
your way in term then it's like an
envelope that's opening up for you
without sounding or you know using that
as a partner terrible but at the same
time I'm not so much interested in their
boobs or their bum and what their body
can do their flashes in my head Believe
it or when they'll go while I'm talking
to him I can see them having a great
time
um and then after that they start to
look at is it to say you're nice they
let their barriers down so to speak and
that's not you know it's not a game and
I'm not trying to you know they've got
me there
before you know it they've said at the
end of it I didn't know what to expect
that's one of the best experiences of my
life thank you very much some of them
cry and say I needed that I just needed
that release I was in a marriage where
the man just made me feel ugly
we've all we've all been there with me
so I think there's a lot of that that
goes on from speaking to women who have
had those sort of crappy experiences
um I mean I mentioned this uh but I
think being raised by a mother I was I
was very close with my mother give me a
big help when it comes to speaking to
women one-on-one because all I was used
to was speaking to a woman one-on-one my
whole life you know and I think that
there's a definite lot of Truth in what
you're seeing in that as men we are just
programmed so differently to women
because we are physical visceral
creatures that you know at our base
level or kind of protect us and shag us
yes it's no one's fault that we're
programmed differently and it is just
about like as a man fight we're having
to fight urges yes to give a woman that
level of experience because we do just
want to rip clothes off and look at the
boobs yeah and all the pressures on us
as well
there's times where you you'll finish
having sex
and and whereas you know you look at a
woman and they're absolutely fine yeah
your ass hasn't been gone
in an hour so you know and and equally
if if it doesn't go so well it's on our
you know if if for a man if you uh if
it's a bit too quick or whatever you
know I I do feel like
women
um but also I think a woman's pressure
is more of a mental pressure from my
understanding there they're often
worried about how they look or am I
doing this right or you know is this how
you yeah
um but I think yeah there's a lot of
Truth in what you're saying about making
a woman feel like the barriers come down
because I think only then can a woman
actually
it kind of gets to me because you know
this is what we're saying about earlier
with the husband and wife thing I mean
if you could spice that up a bit it
would it would save so many
relationships on the same side of things
with the woman like you know she's she's
got an expectation of herself and you're
just enforcing that expectation you know
I mean the amount of times I say you got
the best thing or the a recent sort of
thing in the last year the girls have
come to me and I've said do you feel
confident enough to get undressed in
front of me
and they're like yeah I suppose so
because it's you and I'm like we're
going then so they do and they say no
look at you look at your body look at
your curves look at your breasts you're
gorgeous you're absolutely amazing and I
mean that I do mean it Brian they are
the women's bodies to me is wow this is
absolutely fantastic I feel like that's
a little thing that we can do as men
yeah regularly
to just make them feel good that doesn't
take any it's not like you're buying
flowers chocolates you don't have to go
anywhere just hype around and make a
feel great if she feels great she is
going to be way more confident and
you're going to get way better sex
that's exactly right and this is the
other thing I'll say to any woman that's
with me and they all know the same thing
you have to be confident if you're not
going to be confident in that room then
the things that you know I want you to
know that you are the most precious most
beautifulest object in the world when
you're with me and I will show you that
and the other thing is don't leave any
inch untouched take your time suck the
toes play with the feet you know go for
the inner thighs go for the back of the
neck yes there's no hurry you know
people panic and you know a lot of
friends ask me how do you do it and I
say do you know the difference between
me and you and they go well you're
trying to get a [__] I'm not I'm
trying to get in her mind because for me
that's where the attraction is after so
much sex and being able to just does
anyone fancy a bit of fun at any time I
want it's a bit like well now I want
something more you know I want something
that a girl that's going to last with me
look me in the eye and say yes I'm with
you I understand
like I said four hours later everyone's
very happy but again and you know and
the other I'm not sure about the four
hours bro that's a bit that's a long one
for me like this okay I think I think
honestly it's been about six and a half
hours I think it's the longest I've I've
gone there has been a 24-hour things but
that's been on and off and you know in
between yeah exactly a bad couple
tickets yeah
um you know that's my one voice um but
uh literally there is and the Aftercare
as well I mean you know sitting there
once the ladies finishing you're
finished and just gently stroke uh grab
her hair look in her eyes you know
there's a time you don't have to look in
a girl's eyes every time you you know
you want to make love to her just stop
and stop in the middle of sex and look
at her and say look at me there you'll
see what that real person is there's the
fire there's the spiritual side
each stroke is is completely different
to like someone you know it's it's like
that's our meanness I do care enough
about you and I do want you to enjoy
yourself and I want you to feel so
amazing after this
again all the pressure's off for me bro
yeah
this is a really beneficial podcast for
young Lads out there Specialists because
in not not saying I'm an expert but you
know in my you know I've been fortunate
that women have wanted to spend time
with me and I've I've and I'm sure you
know I've let some women down in the
past and I've been pissing all of this
sort of stuff but ultimately the best
experiences are when you make them feel
like they might have for sure and that's
when a woman develops an attachment to
you and when she's really willing to go
beyond any boundary any King that once
they feel comfortable and they trust you
and they're like this man is never going
to make me feel ugly you know it's
you're leveling up and another like
you've kind of already put it
it's like
you know you're talking about reviews
almost like it's you want a woman to
look at you like I'd go back there for a
meal yeah exactly and when the world get
around yeah you don't want to you know
serve a bad performance so and and
um and I think that focusing on what
they're getting out of the experience is
the key because as a man I personally
think it's easy for us to be pleased it
is it's so easy it can be yeah it's a
bit you know I'm kind of not being rid
of exception to the real obviously
because of what I do I have to make them
happy but even even for me as a normal
guy who doesn't do this as a living and
is just wanting to please a woman I just
think focusing on her for a good amount
of time at the beginning at the very and
just listen yeah yeah and and go go
through those um those motions with her
to focus because for me I know people
make silly jokes about this because
whenever you talk about sex in public
it's a bit of a well how funny but let's
be mature here
focus on making the woman happy to start
with in my opinion is always a good rope
definitely definitely then after that
it's just everything's just a bonus oh
yeah after that I'm doing a Victory lap
and it's it's you know what I'm saying
exactly yeah it's a top end yeah it is
you're not because there's men it is you
know in and out very fast usually you'll
do the trick at any point the hardest
thing as well I think for a lot of women
to admit is they like to be [__] excuse
my French when I say this but you know
but they do a woman likes to be
taking control of absolutely you know
being there's the man there's the woman
that's the object we play in the in the
bedroom not for everyone sometimes we'll
swap rolls you know it can go the other
way but at the same time for a man it's
kind of like you know you just want to
make them feel good you want to make
them feel amazing but almost to our I
guess to our uh detriment because
you kind of want to build up to that
point whereas as a man we're already 100
mile an hour from the get-go yeah so I I
definitely think that this is healthy
that younger younger men can hear that
have build up the wet Lads like yeah as
you say it don't leave any insurance
yeah and that is the thing you take your
time you just don't put the pressure on
yourself you know at the end of the day
you're only human you've got the same as
everyone else has got we're all
different sizes different colors and God
knows what but it and it doesn't mean
about the size or anything like that I
mean I'm lucky but at the same time it
doesn't mean nothing about that at all
that one touch could do it you know in
the right environment the right words
whisper in the air you look absolutely
magnificent now I'm going to devour you
I'm gonna eat you you know I'm his I'm
his okay
yeah sorry I can't see why this works
there's a moment there but this is the
thing and and by Haydn about you know
sex and things like that it's not doing
the youngsters any favors and my second
book is literally based on the simple
fact of like okay the aftermath of
gigolo the aftermath of how people have
changed how people have sinner what's
happened with the females sort of things
no for instance there was an issue a few
years ago where you know at certain a
couple of people tried to come and get
me because of the team up and they
turned up at my door with bad intentions
me being me was polite you know I said
well what is all this about well I've
done you know I don't because of your
book yeah and upsetting women and of
course I've turned them down so they
don't like it like you say they get very
nasty about it before you know it he hit
me he pushed me he done this he done
that and I'm like no I didn't I didn't
do any of that do you know do you know
what I mean so to speak okay so you just
just yeah
you were in a scenario where you've
rejected a Woman based on your
reputation she wanted to sample the
gigolo yes and you politely declined
yeah in which case she didn't take that
too well and accused you of certain
people and they came looking for you oh
she was threats and all sorts it was she
was getting all her groups of friends to
try and go out with me and things like
this and I was like that you've all got
the wrong idea basically I turned it
down and she didn't like her and the
reason I turned it down is because I
said the same thing as what I said to a
young girl about well three nights ago
you know do yourself a favor I can't
give you what what you want I can't give
you that relationship the marriage and
everything else like that I can give you
a bit of fun I can make your life seem
better and stuff like that's not a
problem but I'm not gonna lie to you I'm
not gonna you know this is the other
thing yeah I'm gonna do this I'm gonna
take you out and I'm gonna don't lie to
someone just tell them the truth it's a
bit of fun it's a bit of fun if it isn't
it isn't you know
I must admit years later she texts me
and so I'm so sorry and she apologized
to me and said I was out of line I was
out of order I was in a very dark place
and going back to this this committee
yes and you mentioned before about
um being kind of afraid of of the
potential consequences
I mean
you've never named those people
specifically no there's good reason for
that I'm I'm not one for name and Shaman
if they were in the room here now with
me then fair enough I'd go at it with
them it's not a problem but they're not
and they never will be secondly I think
it was the case of once you've done that
first deed that first night that's what
the very intelligent lady was there for
to set up that scenario get being
trapped and trapped me basically
then at that point they've got me I know
um people like David I have told I don't
know if you're familiar with David sorry
conspiracy theorist but but he often
talks about how the elite
um basically bring each other into the
circle of trust yes and it's often by
getting them to commit a deed that is a
shameful act yes in front of certain
members and it's almost in like oh
you're initiated now we we have you and
it does feel like a little bit of what
you were subjected to as a young man was
very much kind of like that way well you
can't just go running out now and if you
do get trusted in there then they're
very very clever and very smart on
making you feel like you're a part of
them then all of a sudden just
disbanding you and that's the bit that
you know kind of like as a therapist you
get it you get you become very friendly
with some people clients the next thing
you know they haven't got the money
anymore
okay so you mentioned about a man who
wanted your services yes have you ever
had anything with a man and not that
there'd be any judgment nor should there
be but no not at all I mean I'm not
gonna lie I've been in groups of 100
people who've gone to maybe not more
that have all been naked all in the same
room so there's definitely something
that's happened sometimes the light has
been off and I don't even know if it's a
woman to handle a man's hand just
grabbed it you know so I can't say yes
or no what about this hundred people
thing what the hell are you what the
hell happened there that was the party
um when the mask when the mass balls now
usually what happens in these parties
this is the thing you see the front of
it and you see what goes on the separate
rooms and stuff but some of these rooms
have been done up with like glory holes
and all sorts and there was this one
place I went to that had different rooms
and different genres of sex going on
some are tied up you know everything
there was a dark room where you walked
in and anything went
now that was the room I said where it
was had 100 people that felt like 100
people there's a dorm room you kind of
get a glimpse of all these naked bodies
I remember being there for about half an
hour literally with the person that I
was with and we had a bit of fun and
then we went off on our own and done our
own thing but at the same time once
you've been in that environment where
there's a hundred people and that's a
guess there could have been more you
know are we talking like Eyes Wide Shut
mask kind of sort of thing yeah and it's
the yeah the the mask ball where they
all turn up the mask on and you don't
know who it is everyone's just shagging
with a mask on basically yeah what was
it like for you going from the first
time I suppose where people were
watching you or did that did that help
or did it bother you or I'm not gonna
lie to you inside always all the while
you know I sat there and I said oh God I
don't know but again I was young you
know I don't know I'm a different man
now if they put me in that situation now
whatever let's go for and they only live
once who cares
um but afterwards this is the point it
was amazing it was just an experience
and a half where I was allowed to lay
back and let all these things happen and
you know it was the hand I was just I
was in my awe and the thing is after the
fact this is the thing you know as well
as what I do once a man's finished
that's when the thoughts come in oh he's
like you know that sort of thing so
after the fact I was a bit like oh my
God I'm disgusting so I went to the
shower I showered stood in the shower
for about 20 minutes scrubbing scrubbing
and scrubbing I've found a lot of people
have got their own motives their own
intentions they're there for something
not for anything else now the one thing
I learned with the other side the
Olympians as I call them the committee
is leverage yeah with leverage you don't
have to raise a finger you don't have to
raise a fist you don't have to phone the
police if you've got leverage on someone
they're in your pocket for the rest of
it and that is the one thing that they
taught me more than anything and I've
put it to the test and it does work
you're right if you get leveraged on
something and whisper in their ear
behave yourself they soon step back what
kind of Leverage did you notice these
rich people had on other people and how
did they exercise that power the little
things you'd hear about some neat MPS
like you know you'll have the labor over
there the conservative over there and
the rest of them doing their own bits
and you could you can tell who then and
the bankers of the wolf pack as I used
to call them they were completely
different breed you know completely
different how did they all differ well
this is the thing the difference was all
about the money did you ever hear them
talking about like serious politics and
that yeah a couple of times there was a
couple of things especially when it was
um I mean at the time we had a lot going
on in Iraq and stuff like that and that
scared me because again they were
talking about things that were happening
like you know without going too much
into details about military operations
that were going on and I was a bit like
I don't really want to know this
ignorance is bliss so for you to get to
a scenario where you're seeing someone
who's very powerful dressed as a baby
um and you're throwing water on them or
whatever was going on you must have been
quite involved with a lot of the guys as
well as them as the wives it was a group
of gentlemen sitting in the back and I
know for a fact one of them was an MP
and it was also cabinet minister there
and you know Charlie good you guys can
give her a good jolly good go of seeing
too save me [__] doing it tonight
like take the dogs for a walk
and I'm sitting there and I'm thinking
okay great so I'm gonna give you know
and you can take the daughter walk
fantastic you know can you imagine
what's going through my head at the time
I'm like okay she's naked on the couch
you're all sitting there having a
conversation about what's going on in
the world of God knows what
but I soon learned to switch off well
you could have went to the newspapers
and if you want I could have done I
could have gone at any time and you know
there was a few Publishers uh that come
out that were obviously in these mix of
people that said I'll publish your book
tomorrow if you write up
and I said well actually I do write
books I've been writing since I was a
kid I love writing this is fantastic
I've got fantasy novels fictional ones I
mean I've tried to stay away from my own
life but that's all they cared about
they wanted the nitty-gritty
and then it weren't until years later
when I started to think actually I've
got nothing you know I've got I'm
working my ass off my kids have got
nothing you know I I want something in
this life to say that I was here at this
time and after what I've witnessed I
think that's only fair for people to
know the truth and the truth is they
don't care we're just a number knowing
like how amazing the story is to people
listening at home and knowing that
you're also written other books there
will be people who are skeptical of the
story you haven't named because there
will be people who thinks well he was a
writer as the embellishing in his own
story
um what do you say I mean you know you
never believe everything here and you
never believe unless you see it with my
own eyes I wouldn't believe it but I
mean the book is embellished I'm not
gonna lie to you I mean it was wrote for
a film sake or a series in a sense you
know like I said I call it a spider I've
got nothing to hide you said the book is
embellished yeah it is it is I think
every book is obviously where the ghost
writer involves so they tried to throw
the scent of where I was what I was
doing and so it allowed them to play
with the truth a little bit for me it
was as long as you get the main core of
the story and what happened in those
parties I don't care what you're right
for me I just want people to see what
went on Behind These closed doors so
what level of drug use did you witness
cocaine it was a massive thing it was
mainly cocaine huge amounts or oh yeah
like a pile let's just take a part on
the table Yeah but that ain't just the
one pile and it is I just hope that you
know that they read this corner story
knowing their heart hearts every Rule
and law that these guys make for us is
broken by themselves
especially after what you went through
because I assume there were periods
where you didn't feel great about
yourself you may have feel used and and
I mean I'm assuming there will be people
watching now who may have a problem with
you know your line of work because I
know I mean I don't know how it differs
from men to women I I guess you may have
spoken to some women but you know as a
male prostitute
how did that impact you mentally and how
did that make you feel
you become a loner you don't really have
many friends because of what you're
doing you know you know the phone's
ringing and you're off you go you can't
explain that um you detach yourself from
society in a sense and you live in your
own little bubble
um the other times I come home and some
of the things
I didn't enjoy I didn't enjoy dinner at
all I come home like I said I'd be in
the shower and I would be washing and my
friends at home a bit of a clean freak
everything you know colleague was that
as a mental thing as much as physical
mental thing yeah and and for me it was
it was like three times I have to do it
in the show three times I don't think
wash wash wash make sure everything's
clean kind of like all CD Vibes can't
smell I you know I'm getting naked with
these people I have to smell pristine
every inch of me has to smell good what
were the things that made you
particularly
uh uh I guess feel like you had to scrub
yourself down that much like but there's
certain things yeah uh you know when
you've got kids in the family at the
time of nieces nephews I'd kiss them on
the cheek and stuff you know and I
wouldn't let them even come and kiss me
or you know I wash my hands constantly
before I touched them or picked them up
because
I've been doing things obviously sexual
Muslims covered in God knows what you
know so really so it wasn't necessarily
the act it was more what you were then
going to do after the act or was it the
act as well the the Act was sometimes I
mean there was one occasion where I got
wrapped up in cling film and covering
baby all and my appendage was the only
thing that was sticking out and I
honestly wow yeah and and I'm like I
thought okay where are we going now
we've got the morgue or something you
know we can imagine what's going on the
back of my head you know like you say
you know was this was this her thing oh
she loved it that was the fact because
if the cling film was sliding and oily
enough she could slide up and down my
body as much as he wanted basically and
I couldn't move my arms so she could put
where she wanted and I couldn't breathe
sometimes yeah it was all a part of the
show so it's been yeah
but at the same time I mean that was
that was unique and things like that and
I remember also an alization and
alization's nose gone
somewhere and you know while I was in
the middle of something with a certain
lady I jumped and you know oh she went
and I was like oh God it's a dog you
know it's okay she looked the dogs to
watch
of what leads you know little things
like that there's you want like a collar
and stuff each to their own you know
each to their own [__] I'll do it I
mean I mean personally I like to do it
with my hands and my mind you know and I
think you can create anything with that
that's enough for me but I've been tired
and stuff and it's been round I wouldn't
even know what's called a ferris wheel
but you know and they've literally I've
been like this and I'm spinning around
in this bloody wooden thing and and you
know
yeah I'm like this is great you know so
this is the this is exactly what you
were referring to although when you say
they get bored yeah and they just need
more and more crazy extreme [__] yes
plus cocaine yes I mean it's a known
fact as well that these days a lot of
the rich I mean I know people that do
this for a fact it was nothing that I
have done but they they pay people to
Blackmail them they'll send them
pictures of them doing indecent acts and
then say to them you'll blackmail me
and they get Kink off that yeah I've
heard of this before there was a girl I
was friends with who
um was asked by I mean her profession
was you know webcoming and stuff yeah
and she she had this guy sort of ask her
like threaten me to show this to my wife
and stuff and I was like [__] hell
and they pay wild yeah they're painful
yeah I mean that's like he's like a
knock on I'm gonna [__] tell you what
I'm like how did you do this I just need
the money yeah
wild no it is unless this is what's come
to like you said that was that thing you
were saying over on this person's a very
strong businessman he's in control of a
thousand people their jobs their lives
and everything he has to be seen as
being properly so when the cameras
aren't looking and there's no one around
like you say that's where you know they
change you'll find the most strongest
men
forgive me if this sounds out of thing
but that I've got this thing about
usually the most homophobic man you'll
ever meet but they are bisexual they
just don't know or don't want to admit
to it oh you know it's so what but that
fight inside them because of what we're
born and bred to believe or what we're
on a robot into in a sense yeah we've
all seen those outwardly homophobic men
who you're like you just love dick yes
yeah
the best part is when they can't think
it do you see men like a no no sorry I
don't like they walk I think oh [__]
it's a level like as someone who's
always I feel like stressed out and and
kind of in control having a woman in bed
being control is fun I I and I like
being able to switch off and and let the
woman be the one you know what I mean
and this is the other thing as well some
people choose drugs some people choose
alcohol some people jump out of
airplanes to get that buzz I'll use it
in the bedroom that's my Escape I'm a
completely different person in that
bedroom
I you know for me all my worries all my
work everything just goes the stress
just goes away because I've spent four
five hours whatever
not thinking about all that exactly I'm
pleasing now for me it's about pleasing
the other person I get
a turn on from seeing the other person
enjoy sex so the more they come the
better it is for me and then obviously
sometimes I don't even bother it depends
whether they want me to or not and I'll
just move on to the next one you know
that was kind of like that sort of thing
but you know you have multiple clients
in a day but then uh is that normal yeah
the most I ever done I kind of knew this
question was coming the most I've done
in a week was eight
um and the most I've kind of done in a
day is three and that was literally I
mean it was ridiculous I mean people
would just think you wouldn't believe me
unless you followed me around and saw me
but I'd go to a house here
and 300 meters down the road to go to a
house there after being here and then I
go home were they all aware of it were
they cool with that they didn't want to
hey a lot of the girls in a sense kind
of want a little bit more after a while
they all fell in love with me I mean one
girl she told me she had terminal cancer
and she had three months to live
she's still alive now just to get my
attention and I me and me took the time
with her put my effort into her I give
her I'm not and that's brutal black oh
there's so there's still I'm I feel like
I'm still unpacking this whole
experience with you from the bits that I
read in the book it seemed to say that
you had a part now while this was going
on yeah no I I met she turned out to be
my wife in the end we did get married in
here we had three kids together and you
know we got on really well she's a great
girl and she does amazing body kids I
mean I couldn't ask for a better ex-wife
I forgot to be honest was this sort of
cool or was this something that was
unknown yeah no it was on them when I
first met her I was doing it at the time
and it was about six months after that
we were together when I stopped and I
basically give up all of that for her
and the books and everything like so
they were asking me for the book then
and I said no I'm not going to write it
I kind of felt these people were my
friends
you know
um at the same time it got to a very she
come home early one night and won the
clients had just left and I think she
knew at that point
and every now and then when the money
was tight I went out and got the money
we needed but I had no choice I mean
what am I going to do am I going to pick
up another part-time job for minimum
wage and work 24 28 hours a day or am I
going to go get the money for the shoes
that on the nieces and nephew needs for
school because nobody else could afford
it so unless you know and that was
mainly my intention at the time walking
into a shop with a Panama pocket was not
an enjoyable experience
so that was always been in my life but
it's never been as the fact for my kinky
pleasure it was just a means to an end
it means to survive basically
so but after we got married
stopped completely that's where I draw
the line because if someone's going to
put a ring on my opinion and give me the
respect to do that then no and that's
where it kind of dwindles away into
nothing and when years later I thought
well that's I'm going to write it now
I'm going to write Maya thing and I
didn't expect it to take off I didn't
expect anyone I thought you know I'm
just going to be but as long as I get it
off my mind I don't really care was
there any other experiences that were
mind-blowing and wild in these crazy
Rich parties I I think also as well like
that I don't know what uh what's the
word categorize anyone or put them in a
stipulate or anything if that's the
right word but it's a sense of the mummy
and Daddy's boys and you know like when
they talk about their mummy and daddy
they're like 40 years old and they go
mummy Daddy and they've got those issues
and you kind of see it in their sexual
acts if you don't be noticed when
they're wearing nappies or they're being
told they're a naughty boy and they
can't go to their room and drink their
milk and read their bedtime story
so that isn't a sexual in in a sense
it's more like mental isn't it it is but
to them it's sexual they're getting
turned on by this they're getting turned
on by the fact that somebody's kind of
like their mother figure if you know
what I mean just tell them what to do
what a father figure even
um there's so many like I said I could
list the line off of you know I said
that I've worn a lead before I've been
dressed up in all the gear and you know
all little things like that are you DSM
Styles yeah BDSM is a massive thing yeah
massive thing for these guys I mean it
was it was the case of more of anything
than being tied down and tied up in
certain areas you know when you know
what you don't have a piece of rope you
couldn't pretty much tie anyone up in
this situation where you it's an easy
access should we just say that yeah
but mine was a bit more because of the
massage side of things it was that's
what they all craved it was the
essential side of the massage and
getting to know on the spiritual side
feeling completely I mean as we know
five percent or 15 the body starts
posting producing endorphins when you
get a massage that are close to sexual
activity you start to get horny that's
the reason why massage is so close to
sex yeah because that that scene is a
very
I don't know I've had massages before
where I've felt those sort of beginnings
of of a
erection yes I need to start thinking
about something else here but what
you're saying is it's quite a normal
feeling to have in that sense yeah
definitely definitely I mean you know
there's been plenty of times we're not I
have give a male client and he's got you
know excited and he's embarrassed
completely embarrassed but I suppose
they're half asleep and then like you
say they're being rubbed all over it
you're not really thinking well exactly
and I don't think that's me because I
think because I've had a few celebrities
say to me I want a female
and I'm like well I'm not I'm not that
way you're safe you know and they're
like no no what a female if men are out
there you know are thinking about how do
I give my woman a good old massage with
with the minimal skills that we're gonna
have you know we we don't have the
specific training you have but if you
got any advice out there for men who
want to set the mood definitely I mean
just literally use your hands warm them
up first that's the best thing ever but
it is also like little things like
feathers you know you could use a
feather or even like even if we're
sitting here right now I could use that
candle I could use that lead over there
I could use a piece of that Branch over
there to tickle of Robotics on the side
of her bag now that will stimulate her
lymph nodes which are trying to embody
into a crazy shiver and she'll get goose
bumply and then all of a sudden I'll
spray Ice Cold War on her back
so it's a kind of I'm taking every sense
that that person's got whether they're
blindfolded which obviously gives you
more touch and sound whisper in the air
you know you know you know and and
straight away they go oh my God and it
is because the whisper even now don't
know I'm getting goosebumps you know and
you just little things like that play on
people's senses
so when it comes to massage literally
don't jump yourself on the body try and
get them on the side of the bed and
start on the side of the bed and slowly
integrate your body to their body so
start with your hands and then go to
your body once your body is on top of
them and you're giving them the massage
in the back you can use your body weight
just use the airflow ice dips you just
go up the center of the spine don't
touch the spine at all and go out and
back I'm assuming you're you're applying
oil yes yeah and nine times out of ten
I'll use baby oil and the reason being
it's easier for what I do and secondly
not many people are allergic to it when
you start messing around with different
things you only want one allergic
reaction and that's your unfinished I'm
struck off I know you know let's be
honest make one run move as a therapist
I've had it so to speak but it is the
little things and patience as well put
some music on put a candle on roll a
cigarette if you smoke and smoke up
while she's laying there naked and
admire her body that alone is given the
anticipation of a oh this is going to
start in a minute anticipation is a big
thing for you it feels like you're
you're very uh in tune with the mental
side of what a woman is thinking and
feeling and playing with those senses
and just slowly building her up to that
point is a real winner
because women do take a lot longer to
get excited they do we forget that yes
and I understand that in in just a you
know quickly and off you go so to speak
it it's a it's a sense of for me what
makes me different to everybody else is
every sense of that person they're
hearing their sight their smell their
sound their touch everything is explored
in that session
so and it can be done in different areas
like we'll start off with a touch side
of things and then we'll go for the
blowing
just gentle step back you know a drip of
water that runs down the spine into the
the sort of you know the the butt cheeks
so to speak I mean that in itself is a
oh if you know what I mean it sounds
ridiculous then you've got the shower
then you change the environment and then
you say well we'll put a little bit of
role play and I'll be the prison master
and you're going to be my slave today
vice versa I'll do what you want to ask
me and then they're nine times out of
ten this is a God's honest truth if I
say to a god do you ever want to swap
the rolls no no I love it just just do
what you do so realistic they get this
idea of like I'm gonna get him to do
this and I'm gonna get him to do that
and they'll all end up saying the same
thing
I'll just let you take care of it and I
go yeah that's that's the best way
because in that way I know what you want
realistically before they even monitor I
know that sounds crazy but you can just
tell by some people they're uptight and
they're stressed and I think the best
thing about it for me
is after we're finished the look on
their face the confidence in them and
just that whole fact of their whole
Persona has gone from
to
yeah I'm alive I'm alive and and my
massages that I've had in the past that
were good are the ones that you know you
you almost leave their feeling like oh
my God I'm knackered now I feel like
just totally all of the tension is just
gone and when you're talking about the
heat
um and the cold I had a hot Stones
massage which was very good yes yeah
um I did themselves they're honestly
they're brilliant absolutely been very
good for muscles very high impact and
stuff
I'm a great believer in all my clients I
tell them I know information that you've
done that's what makes me stand here and
you don't so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to give you that information and
I'm going to tell you how to fix
yourself this is why I'll never be rich
because if my clients come to me they're
fixed in two to four sessions at the
most no matter how long they've had the
injury
I've got a 99 uh you know clear rate of
every person that I've had I've fixed
the one percent I'm still waiting for
you know I'm gonna I'm not gonna be
explaining to say 100 but and it is just
saying like look you know everyday
little things like for instance if
you're sat on a computer all day with
his hand automatically your brain sent a
signal to the end of that finger and
using just as much blood and much
muscles as you need to do that
excuse me it's the same when you sit on
the phone for too long you're like this
it's because your muscles are shrunk
there's not enough blood in there your
brain looks at something and says that's
how much muscles you need to pick that
up now when it comes to a massage and
stuff what I'm trying to say to people
is your body
is like a car engine so I've got a tune
and I tap into that tune I hear that
tuna if the rhythm is out of place and
it means one of the meridian points are
one of the channel points or you're
holding stress from something nine times
out of ten actually ten times out of ten
is stress that does it for me worry
about money or whatever
we work on those links I get them to
appreciate what they're doing what's
making them bad now two things major
things in this world I see regularly is
people hold stress in their shoulders or
their butt cheeks you'll see people with
either no butt cheeks which means
they're doing this all along they're
touching their butt cheeks and they're
moving their legs and they're standing
they're talking to all matter they
restricted the blood from the lower back
it's going to cause a problem for the
lower back you're gonna have spine
problems then it's going to ride up to
the back you're going to stop holding
your breath because while you're doing
this you're holding your breath so now
your brain's not getting oxygen the
stress starts coming your body panics I
think why am I feeling like this it's
the simple fact that you are tensing one
of your muscles in your body for men
mainly is here we get in a car we do
this
relax my shoulders relax my shoulders
and that's all it was it weren't a
massive muscle industry it was just
about that person going actually I need
to get perfect balance and yeah so I say
to him you know your body better than
what anyone else would now I do this
thing at night I lie on the side and I
sleep on the floor
and uh when I sleep on the floor I'd
take three deep breaths in and as I
breathe out I move one leg this way into
a recovery position I switch to the
other side
and as I breathe out all my oxygen as
much as I can my back goes
but it all like lines in the line and
stuff so just by breathing and relaxing
and knowing that you can control those
muscles because you've been working with
them for so long it kind of like every
night I go to bed I wake up a new man
because I'm like oh there we go we're
back in line you know how that feels I
think everybody does these days
I mean the the shoulder thing for a man
you bang on as well and I didn't really
realize this until I started boxing
because
when you box the more uptight and tense
you are the worse you throw and
ironically then the natural thing for us
as men to do when we want to hurt
someone as we tends up we're like I'm
gonna [__] kill you but the reality
is the more loose and relax you are the
better you are at throwing punches
everything flows and it's nice and fast
and
um I apprecially said be like water this
is it yeah be free-flowing and and do
what you need to do and um you clearly
are very knowledgeable in regards to uh
the body and one topic I'm definitely
interested to ask you about is oral sex
yes because I'm sure knowing women as I
do that you uh have a degree in that is
so what is your philosophy when giving
women oral sex oral sex I again it's not
how you do it it's what you're doing if
you're just like you're not
uncomfortable with yourself and you open
the legs off you go that's not you know
start off at the top really the neck and
then go to the hip and then work
yourself down to that area but while
you're there
everyone's different everybody's
different I mean you know there's some
women like a rough a bit tough on the
tongue and the other women like it just
gently you've got to try and figure out
which one it is no touchwood every
single one of them is completed
further I do hear occasions of my
friends telling me I'll say afraid you
didn't do nothing I said change it yeah
Jimmy I should change it just stop for a
little while you know if you're going
down the same as everything in life
you're going to the path and you're just
running a brick wall you don't keep
doing it you stop didn't you it's the
same thing as all sex weird listen you
don't keep running in that brick wall
take it women vary a lot throughout my
experience from
um and that is the most fascinating
thing about the vagina like isn't it
it's a little magic little thing though
because sometimes you're uh that you
feel like you've got it completed with a
woman and then you'll meet a new woman
and it's completely absolutely different
it is yeah everyone's individual but
again you mix it up you know one of the
clients she used to meet me on my lunch
time and I'd lay on the end of my bed
with my head on the end of the bed she'd
pull her [__] to one side and sit on
my face and I'd do what I've done and
she'd leave that was it that was just
the power thing of that I didn't have to
do anything else about them just lay
there so to speak
fantastic because she was gorgeous but
yeah but at the same time this was a
lawyer you know and I'm thinking imagine
if I ever see you in court how awkward
is this that makes sense though yeah it
does yeah for a loyal a female lawyer to
be that way like
yeah but again change it you know a lot
of people like a woman if you asked I
mean a lot of girls I know haven't had
an orgasm through intercourse that is
just oral and I'm like well change it
around a bit there's a spot you've got
to find the spot so to speak uh also
like I said get them to sit on top of
you get them to do how would you like me
to do this do you want to be bent over
while I'm doing it or do you want to be
sitting on my face do you want to be do
you want to tie me up and then you know
take full control because that's another
Power thing for people isn't it
um and you just mix it up but you kind
of with all sex and stuff you just gotta
just take your time and be you and
explore what you want to explore but
also let your partner know that's the
thing with me one good thing about my
book is they all know that I'm into some
kinky stuff I like doing some stuff so
they all already admitted actually this
is going to be something special now
that's the other downside to it I've now
got to live up to that expectation and
you know as well as what I do it depends
on when you wake up in the morning you
feel for the day it varies bro you know
and also for the woman like there's
someone women out there who probably say
about me that I'm [__] in bed and I'm
like oh [__] with you doesn't mean
I'm like okay yeah I am you know I think
some women forget that you know some
days you're feeling better and some
women bring out the best in you and some
women just you know lay there and on on
that interactive and I usually find the
people that say you're sitting bed are
the ones that have worse themselves uh
you know what I mean they are the ones
that say you want to point the finger
the worst ones are a lot I had a similar
experience though is because I I
basically got a a girl um leaped my DMs
once and they were the worst possible
damns when the the ones you send when
you're drunk as [__]
um but ironically a lot of men were like
slagging me off of that and I'm like oh
meanwhile bro yeah a lot of women are
reading them yeah exactly for a bit of
whatever you want to do because you're
[__] wild you're not boring you're
not yeah yeah exactly but not being
boring is is a blessing for a star it is
it is and that's the thing you know you
know you you look at some people they
sit in the room for now not say a word
and you're like the point you know as a
that's the one thing with me I'll always
just whoever comes if you've turned up
at my house tomorrow it'll be a bed for
you to stay and you'll be well looked
after that's how we are as a family you
know and for me I think people know that
when they walk in so automatically they
relax they're you know they don't have
no expectations and I think half the
time they just Chuck themselves in the
bed and could do your worst I'm like
okay are you sure about that what about
um I'm interested in what you think
about anal sex because that's a taboo
for some people I'm sure it's very
um you know mild for you at this stage
but
um some women love it some women
terrified of it yes what's your
experience oh this is a this is a very
good question this is something that
I've been in any every woman that I've
you know in the last year should we say
have been very dubious about anal sex
they're very oh I don't know I'm not
sure because I I don't know if this is
your experience but in my experience as
someone who's very laid back and you
know happy to warm up the area and do
the see each other with you know there's
a lot of men out there yeah who just
seemed uh spit on it and go for it and
they tear up like they scar a woman
exactly and they [__] it for the rest of
us exactly so stop doing it yeah you
listen [__] belly stop it it's not a
mallet this is an instrument remember
that okay so what yeah what is your
experience like you say warm it up get
them and they have to be exactly happy
with it as well I mean you know it's
something but the one thing I will say
is once we've gone through the process
that I usually do to get to that point
because they want to try or you know I'm
thinking like so what give it a go it's
not really on the top of my list I've
got to be honest but at the same time
every single one of them had an orgasm
for her and they had the best orgasm in
their lives now even when it comes to
oral sex you've got a finger use it you
know what I mean there's the bum you
know and and it does it doesn't have to
be rough or anything like that but it
will transform their sex to another
level it does you can does incorporate
that yes exactly and you know when they
orgasm and come through it they're like
oh my God and then they can't get enough
of it it's oh should we do it
yeah it's basically and you know again
I'm only human there's times when things
happen when they come around six can be
quite messy but you've got to take that
out of your head you've got to get out
of your head and think see the person
you know forget all that that's natural
don't don't expect the you know go out
in the rain and not get wet as well but
but also come on we're all grown ups
here you know what I mean and I'm I'm
sure that when people are listening and
we're giggling away as we're seeing this
it is a bit of fun but we're all [__]
grown-ups yeah this is
and we all walk around pretending like
this doesn't happen yeah because we're
civilized and whatever but we're all
[__] animals I just saw he's gone on
through the years that animal Instinct
has been switched off and forgotten
about
people like us we tap into it because we
can't forget about it we're made to keep
having that and I that's where I say to
people in the sense that animal instinct
is good in the right environment don't
grow smashing people's brains in take a
woman and show her the best time of
their life with that animal Instinct um
I growl I scream you know I do
because that's just like what you know
you know women like a man who isn't
afraid to let it yeah exactly and you
know like I said the animal kingdom I
think we could learn a lot from that and
like Einstein said we've got to start
looking at our past before we understand
our future and for me
who's to say we weren't here before yeah
and you you do say a lot about your you
know your pastor when you were talking
about these experiences that you're
providing these women with that there's
there's
I don't know in order for you to get to
that sensual level you do seem to think
about the spiritual side of things and
that you're you're providing them with a
service that isn't just physical was
there a little bit of you that was sort
of
saying things to yourself to make
yourself feel better about what you are
offering do you think possibly oh yeah
100 we're always going to sell ourselves
as much as we can but and I'm not saying
that makes it any less real to you oh
yeah of course of course I'd like to say
this is completely different but in my
sense I'm a great believer in action
speak Madden words I could sit here and
fill you all full of crap and everything
you know I'll tell you all the things
but no no but action it's what I do when
I leave here now that I've always lived
My Life by that if somebody's punished
me or accuse me of being something like
you said my actions my life's been my
words I wouldn't even retaliate to her
because as soon as I do I've then
entered a conversation I don't want to
be having what I'll do is I'll get my
head down and my actions will prove what
I've done so if anyone want to come
along and watch and see and learn or
have a girl one of my clients to chat to
and they can tell you their impression
and they're their opinion of it I mean
realistically I'm off on a service and
then look at the Amazon review I suppose
they're the ones you've got to say but
for me personally
there's only one person in this world
who's going to lift my confidence up
that's going to allow me to be me and
that is me and I'm not I've accepted the
fact that I'm not some big time Gangster
or some big time Ron Jeremy or some you
know I'm just a normal guy with a normal
life with a family who had an
opportunity in life and he wrote about
it you are normal in some respects but
you're not normal in others 100 right so
you come out of a scenario where you're
being a young man being used for your
services and a little bit of a tool for
these older women uh to get pleasure out
of and then you know a grown man you've
told this story and this story has then
hit the ears of a lot of these women who
were like wow that sounds like an
experience I want to have that
experience and they're now approaching
you yes you've become a bit of a prize
to some of these women who've read this
book and you know we all seen what the
Christian Gray book did yeah and you're
a real person if Christian Gray was a
real man based on me it would be yeah it
would be a nightmare you know
um so you're you're a real living person
who they can come to and go I want to
have this experience and
now you're the you're the prize so it's
a completely different scenario and no
one is really trained to deal with being
approached not men we're the Chasers yes
you know we're the lucky man who gets to
I don't have that anymore yeah now
you've become the chair oh yeah yeah
that's exactly you've got a situated
reverse roles and that is so weird to be
on the other side of the fence it's like
oh my God you know really so can you
take me through the beginning of that of
course and when you realize okay I'm now
getting messages how did that make you
feel did you make you feel good or at
the time I was literally close to having
a nervous breakdown I suppose and I was
laying in a caravan with no Heating and
no food now my kids were born my kids
were fed but I had nothing I lost
everything and uh you know a messy time
in my life can we explore that then
because I mean I know it's it's not a
nice memory no but but you've been very
candid and there's no shame in in
hitting rock bottom no everyone lots of
people have 100 I mean it was it was a
time when I laid on the floor in my
underwear and I was shaking and I
couldn't stop myself convulsing those
like this and what brought that on then
divorce really I was broken broken in
two it destroyed me my kids are
everything and that just I panicked I
was scared I don't know what's going on
you know I just didn't know what to do
how long had you been married before you
divorced we've been together for 18
years and then 10 years married yeah and
you know even now I'll always look out
for the girl you know I mean I never let
anything come to it because I think the
Wilder vote was well I always loved the
girl do you know what I mean but not but
you didn't want to get divorced no I
didn't know I was it's funny because it
was kind of you know I'd kind of
accepted the fact that there was this
was it and I was happy with that I was
happy with what I had and then two weeks
later it all ended and it was messy and
yeah sorry I'm I'm gonna stop you
um you said you'd accepted that you were
happy what you had and then two weeks
later I was all over yeah so yeah you're
saying you're accounting a memory from
two weeks prior to her asking for the
divorce yes so you were in a comfort
zone oh I think this was sweet so happy
and then out of nowhere yeah now I'm not
a psychologist I wasn't there but but
naturally for someone on the outside you
think if you thought it was fine and she
thought she wanted a divorce then
there's a clear a blind spot there in
your behalf yeah so what were you not
saying do you think I know what exactly
what it was I think I got so wrapped up
in writing the book and getting so
wrapped up and making a point for people
to say
um eager you know this ain't my I can't
have this I just you know I can't live
in a world where people are getting
ripped off left Point Center it kind of
bit away at me do you think you became a
little obsessed 100 100 and then I
neglected her needs and I neglected the
kids in these because for me it was
never enough for them welcome back what
a nice life form you know I've done all
these things I've seen how the other
half lived so I know that it's out there
I got so consumed by all that I think I
neglected my family now I accept that
and I'll always be a good guy I'll
always do the right thing by my family
regardless of what happens
at the time I'd lost everything I ever
cared about everything I ever how did
you lose it because you mentioned you
were in a caravan how did you end up
going from the family home well
basically there was like I said it's a
very messy divorce and you know I was a
school of the property and
um not allowed to go back so basically
my best friend my wife my family and
everything was I weren't allowed why
weren't you not allowed though she I
think for well I can't really talk for
her can I but from my point of view what
I saw is she was quite intimidating and
frightened by me so I think she thinks I
was going to go crazy and throw across
the room and stuff but that was never me
you know I've never done that I've never
hit a woman in my life and I never will
do
and you know again do you mean like you
were having passionate
um arguments or well no this is the
thing we we were it was just out of the
blue it was like one of those things
everything was fine one week everything
was great next minute dang and I was
like whoa what it was just a massive
change all of a sudden for me and it was
like
Jesus
and as time went on I started to realize
that you know the things I have got and
I started to appreciate the positivity
in life and I started to let things go
and think it's not my responsibility to
tell the world that the government are
all perverts and rip people off left
right and Center
you know and and I'll kind of Let It Go
and I concentrated at that time
my kids were devastated they were gone
through so much and I just wrapped
myself around them every second of every
day I mean I threw my whole life into
them I still do know so so we're we're
moving beyond the part where yes sorry
you were you were at a part where she'd
said we don't want you around anymore
yes was that a temporary thing or was
that at the time permanent I know it's
permanent she already made her mind up
and but you know again these things
happen in these times but she'd already
planned everything the money was all
gone already and things like that it
it's kind of there's no fairness in Love
and War and again I don't really hate
anybody or despise anyone for their
their choices in life you know they have
to live and learn by them
all I really I mean at the end of the
day I've got three kids and one of
them's a girl and all I could think
about night after night is who's going
to be around my children
you know what what where are they what
am I going to see him again you know
unfortunately we're in a society where
there's nothing more sexist than divorce
courts and you have no power and what
they say goes and and I understand that
and I am not a person who has any
involvement in your relationship but I
do know that to be true from every man
who's ever been divorced yes ever yes
exactly yeah so so the fact that this
was coordinated and a sort of rug pulled
situation where all of a sudden the
money's gone and you're in a you know a
situation where I've got nowhere to go
nothing so that's why you ended up in
the Caravan yes yeah I mean I did sleep
on the streets I've lived rough I you
know I stepped in my car a few months
ago actually just for some peace and it
was because
I know it sounds crazy you know I work
full-time um I have a lot of jobs and my
other little things but it's just enough
to get by it's like treading on more all
the while you're just you know you're
paying bills left foot in the center
you're trying to keep it and nothing's
cheap anymore you know the kids want the
phones and things and
I don't really have much
need for my life if I didn't have my
children's I'd live in Tibet I'd go and
live in Tibet with the monks and just go
and have a very peaceful life without
all the internet and without anything
I'm very simple
with my kids it stops me from doing
anything I know I accept that I mean
I've been asked four times in my life to
go and be a playboy for someone and get
paid Millions for it in LA California
Scotland and Norwich playful places
I was like wait really you're just
around the corner
every time the question was asked so
would you and this was the deal one of
them would give me sixty thousand pound
I'd move him in the house I'd marry them
but I'd have to be theirs all the while
I've got children well you can see them
once every two weeks or well they can't
come
sorry if my children ain't coming
they're not in so I've turned down a lot
of opportunities for the fact of my kids
and I'm not ashamed to say it but at
that time when the book came out to
answer your question
I laid there with nothing thinking
Jesus I don't know how I'm gonna get
through this literally shaking I could
not stop myself from shaking
and then I stood up
and I thought you ain't got time to be
feeling sorry or bad for yourself at the
moment you've got three little children
that need your strength more than
anything so I put all my worries to one
side
then I went for the book I thought no
there's nothing stopping me now I
haven't got a family to protect or I'm
not married anymore to worry about the
consequences
throughout come the book
after the book I mean that was amazing
there was ladies left right and Center
they were chucking money at me they were
asking me to go to places holidays all
over the place and I was no was this
through social media they were reaching
out social media all social media okay
yeah most of it was Facebook to be
honest with you nearly all of my clients
come on Facebook what kind of air train
shall we talking I'm talking from
literally 22. to actually 63 you know
and and it is a vast Arrangement and all
the different ages but the sense the
youngest would have been 22. so did you
start dating any of these women yes I
did to start off with because I was very
confused and thought what do I do I need
to get back I need to find something you
don't have to justify you know you're a
man yeah you're a single man and if if a
woman who's a good looking woman is
interested in you I don't see why anyone
should judge you no exactly exactly but
again every person I went with I found
that you know I'm not going to be able
to have a life until another 15 years
when they're all grown up and they can
leave so I can't really give anyone my
time or commitment simply because of
that reason they'll always come first
um and then I met a lady we went out we
had dinner she was really well off very
well off and she promised me everything
and looked after she'd read the book
then yeah yes all right and it was on
the context of a you know a business
deal it was when we first met and then I
said you know I won't I'm not I wasn't
that person I was well back then you
know I'm an older I'm a father now I've
worked I've seen life
and I said so I don't really feel right
doing it like this should we date for a
little while you know so we dated
because I'm trying to do the right thing
here
it didn't work it didn't work I got I
don't like the fact of being in a
relationship where you have to tell the
person where you're going what you're
doing where you've been and with me
there's always going to be an issue for
a lady they're always going to say you
get so much attention there's always
going to be something there
apart from the girl that I'm seeing now
I mean she's amazing she takes it all in
the stride and lets me get on because
she trusts me she knows I'm not that
kind of person and I'm honest enough to
tell them as well like you know if this
is the difference and I say it to anyone
that might get you in [__] and stuff but
tell them I'm gonna go and sleep with
someone else I've been offered I mean it
might hurt them I might say oh they're
not good enough for you no it's not that
it's just me I can't settle with one
woman for some reason that's just it
doesn't seem to be enough for me at the
time you know I suppose I was looking
for something that wasn't there I was
looking to replenish my marriage when I
so this is post book release you're now
you're now in a situation where you're
dating but then you're wanting to
explore all these opportunities that are
being thrown you away yes and let's be
real how many men who get any success do
that mean I'm not going to throw stones
because I've made my mistakes
um and it is difficult because we're not
programmed to be the ones to reject you
know I think
women just get a far better education
and how to handle that from a young age
because men are always sort of
approaching them and and only when you
get any sort of status do you end up
having to face that challenge many men
don't really ever experience that and it
is a gift in the curse because all of a
sudden you're then worrying about why
are people interested and you're in a
really weird scenario because you're at
a financial disadvantage because you're
hooking up with these well-off women who
you know they they want your services
but they also want to control you and
it's kind of a reverse situation to uh
sugar daddy yes yeah sugar Mummy I'm the
person there I'm like a a gimmick term
if you know what I mean I'm like the
entertainment for the evening sort of
speaking is exactly it but did you
revert back to that then yeah all those
years later I did yeah it come out this
is what I mean I started doing my
Jiggler work again for the last three
years and then until I sort of you know
delusions of grandeur I mean you know
the the book was out all these ladies
were offering me dates and dinners and
movies and holidays away and presents I
mean it'll bring new phones and you know
like all the different kids you have
like a set rate that you charge them uh
yeah hey again this is where I'm too
nice that would be like well what can
you afford because again the guys that I
was with in the book money was never an
option it was like they throw it at you
but now this is like a people that work
for a living and people that are out
there hard work and they're working all
their life and on the weekend they want
a bit of excitement
income me and you know I thought yeah I
can do this I'm like you know and so I
went three years of still doing what I
was doing back then
and then all of a sudden I just
completely lost interest
I thought that's not me anymore I'm
trying to be something that I'm not
trying to relive my youth I'm trying to
relive my past grow up man sort yourself
out for Christ's sake told myself got
back into training lost a lot of weight
started eating healthily Don't drink
don't do drugs so for me it was a kind
of win-winning I started drinking ball
and more starting to move fast and my
mind started getting stronger I started
to realize
not everybody in this world is as kind
as me do you know what I mean by that I
look at people I think I would pretty
much give someone my left arm if I
needed that with no questions I thought
I've always always been but then it hit
me how far are you gonna go with this
before you're too old or you're washed
up on the shore did you know I didn't
want to be that person so I kind of said
right that's enough now and the reason
another big reason was because I was
getting more and more in the press and
getting more and more noticed
that I kind of felt I've got to be very
careful about how I reply to this now
I've got to be very careful about what I
say all it takes is for me to go up
there and want to come out and God I've
got messages from him that say I'm gonna
come around and do this I'm gonna so I'm
very pulled myself away and I've can't
become quite a family man that's me and
the kids now and just me and the kids
and my partner at home with at the
moment and it's lovely it's nice and I
still get the offers
and there's still part of me that thinks
oh I could I could I could I'm not gonna
lie to you I have
but
I had no choice I know I need to explore
that because that you said there was a
I'm fascinated the fact that you
reverted back all those years later and
and had a three-year period where you
were working again as a gigolo yeah
threesomes it seems to be the most sorry
in the Rapture problem the threesome
seems to be the most popular thing these
days everybody wants a threesome
everybody
it's the way you said that like everyone
this is such a casual wear is there
um and and by threesomes do you mean to
uh women or two men two women or two men
one woman yeah I mean I have a guy that
works with me you know I mean we've
known each other for years so it's a bit
easier yeah yeah exactly exactly and you
know it's it's something I must admit
that I suppose if we do the logic from
what I've seen
about
50 50. you'll either enjoy it or you're
done like a personally I'm a one-on-one
man I mean I do these things and I've
been in the groups and stuff but my my
best time is one-on-one so when you're
in your Mac go around to This Woman's
house is her is there a fella who's
aware of it no no she's she's single and
the girls that have asked me have I ever
been in relationships and they're out of
relationships and in the single phase
and they're like the I want to explore
can you help me out
uh advice to people who want to get into
the business as well so many people said
how do you start how do I get into it
and I've been giving them advice on how
to protect themselves more than anything
and just be very careful so you you have
like websites and stuff that you guys uh
appear on where people can buy the
services yeah there's plenty I mean the
main sort of one am I allowed to say it
or I'd say yeah adult work is is one of
the favorite ones a lot of businessmen
stuff like that I mean I've had people
from London that come and stay in
Norwich and you know ring me up and say
I'm in the hotel can you come and see me
now that gets a bit strange when you see
the same person be on the camera you
keep walking in and walking out again
that's another thing I have to take into
account this person's watching me and
thinking what's he [__] doing do you
know I mean you go in that room we come
out and he's he says everywhere he's
smiling he go see you later you know
I'm thinking if that was me I'd be like
what the hell is going on here you know
so it wouldn't take too long for them to
figure out now again with the kids in my
life I really try and keep that away
from them it's a separate side of my
life
now with the the guy that I ring nine
times out of ten the woman the ladies
that I've met are very comfortable with
me they've sat in my company with
watched movies we've chilled out
together we've made love we've done all
sorts funnily enough they asked me to
make love to him and then after they
couldn't ever make love to me again [__]
me and I'm like okay no worries
honestly honestly the love side of
things is nice they're like no I don't
wanna you know it's like no just a
rather you because again they're still
all touchy feelings in this three-year
period what would you say it was the
average age of these women who are
reaching out because I'm assuming that
women who read books yeah are a certain
age generally and women who would want a
man with your experience you're you're
very specific set of skills that you
have I would say between 30 and 60 30
and 60 would be my sort of range I have
had younger girls and I've said no and
there's a good reason for that you know
I'm old enough to be their dad and yes
they would have the best time in their
life but what I keep saying is just read
the book and if you go with a partner
get him to read it what was it like
going with with a with an older woman
did that did that feel any different
honest that's one of my things I I know
it sounds crazy but
another one's got experience they know
what they want there's no again the
confidence is there not all of them but
a lot of them they know there's no if
and butts about it you know and I
suppose for me it's it's a turn on this
I like I like the older women and I like
I like all sorts you know obviously but
at the same time I can wake up a Monday
and think oh fancy sort of I don't know
30 you know and the next day fancy
something 60. and you know people think
how can you do it but you don't no one's
seeing what I see but it's also I guess
for you a sexual appetite com becomes a
lot like a normal appetite is days where
you just feel like something different
and for that three-year period I mean
how often were you working
in covert on the scene book number two
we'll have you all sitting there with
your mouth open because that was the
most busiest time of my life I have
never been so busy I've never had so
many messages oh God I am not joking I
was starting at six in the morning and
getting home at three the next morning
and getting up at six again and doing
that for four or five days and then
crashing right people around me would
say slow down the most in one day was
three and it was it would sometimes
eight clients in a week would be the at
this stage would be my limit and I got
I've got to be honest I said I've got up
to about a couple of years ago I got to
a point where I was like I can't keep
doing this this is getting like I mean
you know some notes I'd really enjoy it
Brian I'd be like yeah I'm really up for
this and I go from one and then another
and you know and then some of them get
turned on by the fact some of it asked
me where have you been what have you
been doing a lot of them would say tell
me hey what you've been doing this week
they wanted to hear how I was like
another women I turned them on you know
some of them had
um a little side of buying them that
what the choice of them I said okay what
we'll do is I'll talk to you about it
while we're doing it so I'm going to
tell you to imagine that the person
you're thinking of is in front of you
right now and I'm gonna do what I'm
gonna do and we're getting the set and
honestly love it but then they say to me
I couldn't do it for real
in up here it's a good good game but I
couldn't do it for real
in a sense
for me I'm just me I'm never going to be
anything different so when I walk into
any situation like here anywhere else
I'm just gonna be me I'm not gonna lie
I'm not gonna be out and say anything
the only way you could ever appreciate
it is literally by talking to one of my
clients I should imagine I I think
you're being very truthful
um because you're just so specific and
the way you describe sex it's it's from
a man who knows what he's talking about
um and yeah I mean what a life you've
had bro I mean you just I I really felt
the pain when you were talking about
that divorce situation and and and just
putting your children at the Forefront
of Your Mind through that and I think
unfortunately
as nice as it is to know that you've had
so many fun times I really do feel for
uh you and and for having to go through
that scenario because a lot of men feel
really powerless uh in those situations
but I'm glad that you managed to push on
through that because it takes a hell of
a lot of strength you know and there's
there's many men
there's a reason why male suicide is so
high and I guarantee I'd stake my life
on it that divorce and suicide are
directly Linked In men especially 100
because when you take that access away
to their children and when you when you
rip the the the you know the life's work
from them the amount of money that
they've earned and you just leave them
with pennies and you leave them without
their children and everything that
they've been building no wonder these
men are out here killing themselves and
yet no one [__] talks about the
divorce uh lot laws it's a disgrace well
this is what I'm so cautious talking to
you and you know I've got some really
strong views on that and and I don't
because it could just cause me problems
I suppose but at the same time it was
unfair I was drag through the [__] I was
named and shamed my actions had to do
then people slowly started to see
actually he's not that person he's been
made out to be but it's so funny I hope
people will just believe what they want
to believe because that's a new thing
and yet all the people that I grew up
with and known that love me you know I
have a nickname where I come from called
The Guardian Angel because I used to
look after people and make sure they get
home at night and realistically
everybody that knows me knows that I've
helped them in one way or another
everyone I've touched in my life I've
done something for so I had a lot of
people come up because that's wrong he's
not like that at all you know he's not
that person
we all need a reason to do things I just
wish I think the one thing I think in
all couples is take away the hate take
away the revenge
tell the truth be honest say that I'm
not happy this is what's going on in my
life at the moment I would stop all the
confusion but more than anything put the
children first they're the ones that are
in the middle of it all are going to
suffer more than anything
so for me I mean I've spent a lot of
time with Indians and gurus I've spent a
lot of time with influential people as
you know so in my own mind I'm quite
strong enough to say I've got to change
this attitude and slowly but surely
I realized I'm the luckiest man alive
because of my kids
that's all I need I don't care about
anything else as long as they're okay
I'm good it's hard to be a good man it's
not easy no it's not but it is difficult
and you mentioned how you'd have those
lapses where women would come chasing
again and and you know you you'd find
yourself giving into temptation did you
find that you beat yourself up a little
bit when those things would happen yeah
definitely because of the people that
were in my life I think they deserve a
lot more and I gotta be honest they're
good you know and then you know but they
they accept me that's who I am I can't
help that I'm not gonna lie I'm not
gonna say oh I'm not going to cheat on
you I can't promise you that look at me
look at my life you know I mean has your
has your current partner
um have you come to some sort of
agreement yes yeah she's you know
career-minded and I'm I'm obviously
doing my own with the children and stuff
but you know I never judge anyone for
their actions I'll only judge people on
one thing in life and that's how they
are with their children and how they are
with my children so the person I'm with
at the moment is the best person for my
children she means me feel happy and she
puts my kids first in other words she
didn't come into just for me she
accepted them as well and for me that's
more than anything and that's worth not
breaking or messing around on because of
that reason
if that reason changes then you know so
you've managed to stay fearful this yes
yeah yeah yeah yeah
you know the bits off and I've even
explained I've even said to her before
look you know I'm honest I'm so one's
probably too honest but I've said look
there's a girl who's messaged me and
you know her and you know I'm just
letting you know and there's more
response yeah and here's my response
what a friend of hers yeah I don't say
any name she doesn't see the names or
anything because I don't want no trouble
caused obviously you know because that
could you know what I mean but I just
say just so you know and here's my
response and I show her my response and
I say today you go help yourself I've
got nothing to hide
that must be a bit of a
a breath of fresh air for you as well to
finally be free of the shame and the
hidden you know Secrets yes yeah I mean
that's the thing that you say I carried
that myself you know nobody knew about
this apart from myself and that was like
I know I felt like the same secrets you
know Secrets Society it was it was nice
to feel that way in a sense but then as
time went on I realized I was just a
Paddy Wagon form to carry on to the next
guy to come along and then you realistic
it was like well let's see oh what do I
get out of this you know
but at the same time
I'm still gonna get that attention and I
still have friends that are females that
are friends of mine
I think the worst bit for me is the
married women the married women that
come up to me and send me pictures or
ask me to go out and I'm like so what
what's your husband going to be doing
well you know inside
one I'm not going to be like a city
before not going to be the reason for
destroying someone's marriage I've been
there and I'm not that person I couldn't
do it to my worst enemy I wouldn't want
that for anybody I know how it feels
two I have got some morals you know what
I mean I don't think that's right while
a man's at work working his ass off for
me to go around and service his Missus
and smile all the way at the bank that's
not right in my eyes so I give them a
simple advice be honest with your
husband tell them what you want to do if
you're getting bored in the sexual side
of things then either accept it or move
on or do something about it now if he
your husband wants to sit there and
watch then by all means but he has to be
included and he has to know about this
do God Blocked other side of things
they'll come to their place and I'll
look at them face to face and I'll say
to him trust me from my experience not
worth it so are you still massaging yes
yeah but it's purely non-sexual now yeah
you know I've got clients that I've had
for years so to speak and
so your girlfriend's okay with that
though yeah she's okay with the massage
side of things and like I said you know
it's a case I'm not going to say never
because you know I mean the girl I'm
with at the moment we don't even class
ourselves as girlfriend and boyfriend
we're there for each other we're our
best we're best friends you know she's
got my back when it comes to kids and
I've got her back when I come for
everything and there is a lot of love
there there's no it's mutual
understanding and I've already told her
straight to her face that if the book
does its thing and I get an offer
that's going to change my life for my
children's benefit I'm going to take it
because I'd be stupid not to because at
the end of the day Brian the way I see
it is there's only one sure thing about
this life
so in the meantime just don't don't
stress yourself don't worry about it
because you're only going to end up in
one place and what is today's newspaper
is going to be yesterday's tip paper and
all the other way around yeah yeah and
and how long have you had some of these
clients for now at this point oh God
yeah long long time a long long time I I
think a couple of clients I see when I
travel around and stuff in certain
places the company I've known them while
the book was going and while I was doing
what I was doing you know and and you
know that's the thing
um and a lot of them come so close to me
the fact that you know if they have a
problem in their life like you know
Finance or something aiming me and I'll
have a chat with them for 10 minutes
naked you know I don't care you're right
I kind of find myself reinforcing it all
the while and like you say when you get
into a certain stage in life where you
wrote a book or you're in the public eye
people listen to you and they kind of
see you you think well actually I don't
want to give you rubbish advice but
let's just look at this
there's always two sides to every story
there's the truth and not the truth and
who's telling that you know what you
know what I'm saying don't you so in my
eyes what I do it every problem anyone's
got so let's look at the truth let's
look at what you have got to start off
with
okay you're a bit Rocky on this and that
seemed to make them feel better so I'm
kind of relied on as well as that figure
that keeps them calm and keeps you doing
all right you're doing fine everything's
fine you're in exactly the place where
you're meant to be don't try to live
just live that's the secret of it in it
so for me even this today is like well I
didn't expect it but that's great I've
met a really nice really nice people you
guys are awesome tell you oh thank you
so much and um I think we'll we'll we'll
we'll end that there but
um thanks so much for coming man no
thank you I really appreciate the
opportunity massively and I I hope
things go great for you obviously you've
got another book coming out
um what will that one be called do you
know that's a good question yeah I'd
probably Gigolo too that makes well I
was going to call it uh Gigolo to what a
woman truly desires because I've spent
so many years trying to understand what
a woman really wants and you know when
you click on what what a woman really
wants you've you've got it have you seen
the Mel Gibson movie yes he has the
Electric Shot then you can hear women
that's who did what they think exactly
and obviously I worked with women all my
life you know in the industries that I
worked in I was the only male you know
as a therapist it was all women all
women or women I was any male and I I
you see the true side of any day yeah
without going on too much you know they
all have their problems and issues but
some of the conversations are listening
well I'm gonna say make me dip you know
I can't I wouldn't do that that's
disgusting but there's me saying that
but I'll leave you on my last question
that I ask a lot of people which is how
would you like to be remembered how
would I like to be remembered do you
know what a good father is top my list
um and a good friend somebody that is
always there for someone I'm the kind of
guy that if you ring me I'll be there no
matter where you are in the world I'll
be there I am the guy that you can rely
on if you need it and the extension goes
out to all my friends and family they'll
tell you the same thing
um so I'd like to be remembered as a
nice guy
um but also
good in bed fantastic
on the gravestone he was good
um there'd be all these ticks on there
sorry well um
if you want to purchase the book guys
you already know it's uh Gigolo it's out
in stores and Gigolo 2 will be on the
way
um and thanks for sharing your story
mate I really appreciate Ben Foster
thank you Charlie podcast thank you
thank you cheers